Why Blueprints are Blue
Making copies of architectural drawings hasn’t
always been the easiest thing in the world
to do.
For the majority of human history, the most
economical solution was simply to have someone
make a tracing of the original plans.
In the mid-nineteenth century, the process
abruptly became much quicker and easier thanks
to famed polymath Sir John Herschel.
In 1842, Herschel invented a method to easily
copy drawings using potassium ferrocyanide
and ammonium iron citrate.
The exact method, called cyanotype, is performed
as follows.
First, you take a drawing of the plans done
on relatively translucent tracing paper or
cloth and place it on top of and attach it
to paper (or sometimes linen, Mylar, etc.)
that has been previously soaked in a mixture
of the aforementioned two chemicals, then
dried.
Next, you expose the papers to a bright ultra-violet
light source, such as the Sun, for several
minutes.
The result is that the paper soaked in the
chemicals ends up turning blue as the chemicals
react to the light and form a compound called
blue ferric ferrocyanide, also known as “Prussian
Blue.”
This wouldn’t be very helpful for making
a copy of a document except for the fact that
where the light cannot penetrate the translucent
paper, namely where the drawing marks are,
the coated paper remains the original color
of the paper, usually white, effectively making
a nice copy.
You might see a potential problem here in
that you then can’t expose the un-blued
bits to any bright light source at first,
but this problem is easily solved by simply
washing the chemicals off, then allowing the
paper to dry.
At this point, the copy is complete.
Within a few decades of the discovery of this
method of copying (as well as other blue-printing
methods such as one developed by Alphonse
Louis Poitevin in 1861 using ferro-gallate),
the price dropped to about one-tenth the cost
of having someone simply trace the original
plans, helping the popularity of blueprints
explode.
In the mid-twentieth century, copying methods
such as as diazo prints, and then later xerographic
prints, finally supplanted blueprints.
Much more recently, simply sticking with digital
versions of plans has become popular, with
these having the advantage of being easy to
modify and distribute as needed during the
construction process.
Despite the technological changes and the
fact that these plans usually aren’t on
blue paper anymore, in popular vernacular
the term “blueprints” has stuck around
anyways.